Okay, welcome back. We're in video number
16 and we're now going to look at Chinese
GDP. So we're moving to a new economic
region. We've already looked at the United
States and Europe. Now we're going to look
at China GDP and specifically what we're
going to look at is the makeup of GDP in
China and we're going to try and
understand this country a little bit
better.
We're also going to look at the leading
indicators, the main purchasing manager
indexes in China and use these leading
indicators to potentially generate trade
ideas and firstly and most importantly add
it into the mix of our world view.
So when we add US, European and Chinese
GDP together, we're actually getting to
about 50% of the world's income, which is
very, very significant.
Now China's important because it's growing
at 8% a year and one of the main reasons
that it's growing at 8% a year is because
of its export market.
China really is the workshop of the world
at the moment and the export market for
China is 30% of its GDP.
And from the export market, its two
largest clients are the United States and
Europe.
And what you're going to see when we go to
the presentation in terms of the makeup of
GDP and what Chinese GDP depends on, well,
30% of its market is exports, 30% of its
GDP, therefore 70% of it is domestic
demand-led in the economy in terms of
domestic consumption.
But 30% of its export market and its two
largest clients are the United States and
Europe, and combined the United States and
Europe actually make up a third of all
Chinese exports.
So what we actually discover is that for
every 1% drop in US and European GDP
combined, or in terms of looking at it the
other way, additional, we get a move of 10
basis points in Chinese GDP.
So, US and European demand is actually
very, very important for Chinese GDP.
We're also going to look at the makeup of
the PMIs, because this is also really
important.
When we're looking at leading indicators
in China, we have official statistics from
the government, and we also have private
sector statistics that are statistics for
leading indicators made by the private
sector.
And the official stats are made by the
government.
And what you often see in China is a
divergence between the two.
Now, this is because the makeup of these
PMIs is slightly different, but also
because there's a lot of propaganda that
comes from the Chinese government.
And you'll notice when you watch the PMIs
on a monthly basis, sometimes the private
sector PMIs are showing quite different
numbers to the official PMIs.
And professional traders tend to focus
more on the private sector PMIs and not
ignore the official PMIs.
The official PMIs are still important
because they create positive or materially
negative sentiment in the market.
But, as professional traders, we're trying
to cut through the noise.
So, if there's noise coming from the
Chinese government, what we're trying to
do is cut through that and try and
understand the true situation in the
economy.
So, let's go over to the presentation.
Let's have a look at the makeup of the
Chinese GDP, try to understand this
country a little bit better, and also have
a look at the makeup of the PMIs, and also
how we use the leading indicators, the
PMIs, to predict Chinese GDP.
And therefore, include this analysis in
our overall global view, our worldview, on
global GDP.
Let's go over to the stage, and I'll see
you at the end of this video for a summary
of the Chinese GDP.
So, exports in China are 30% of GDP.
So, their export growth is totally
dependent on the demand for those goods
and services from the US and Europe.
Electromechanical products make up 57%, so
labor-intensive products.
And both the United States and European
Union are 17%.
17% of the demand each.
For Chinese exports.
So, what does that mean?
So, if they're roughly one-third of
Chinese exports,
and exports are roughly a third of Chinese
GDP,
that can only mean one thing.
Every 1% fall in the US and Europe in
demand for those products knocks 0.1% off
Chinese GDP.
If the US sneezes, the world catches a
cold.
China is no different.
Now, what's China trying to do to combat
this situation?
Anybody know?
Sorry?
Yeah.
So, they're trying to shift to a more
internally, domestically dependent,
demand-led economy.
But it will take some time.
You get the spreadsheet, so you can see
that as well.
There's a little reminder.
The US will be taken over by China, all
things being equal, by 2025.
And there's two indicators that predict
Chinese GDP.
There's the official PMI, which is
published by the Chinese government.
And there's the private sector, HSBC China
PMI, released by HSBC, which is a bank in
the private sector.
Professional traders tend to focus more on
the HSBC private sector PMI.
Why?
Because there's often divergence between
the two, for two reasons.
One, I hope there's no people watching in
China.
One, because the Chinese government simply
makes the numbers up.
Secondly, the official PMI is a bit more
clunkier.
It's slower to react.
Because the official PMI is the top 300
multinational manufacturing companies of
China.
But the HSBC PMI also includes a lot of
small and medium-sized enterprises
whose earnings are a lot more sensitive to
the business cycle immediately.
Because they lose one client, and their
earnings are wiped out.
Whereas the big multinationals are more
diverse.
So in terms of reliability, professional
traders really like to look at the HSBC
PMI.
There's never a huge amount of difference,
but sometimes there is.
Generally speaking, there is a huge amount
of difference, but sometimes there is.
I mean, last year, for example, for nine
months from, I think, October, November 11
to June, July last year,
the HSBC official PMI was predicting, the
HSBC private sector PMI was predicting a
slowdown in China, contraction.
But that was one of the reasons, for
example, in March last year, why I shorted
Hong Kong property stocks that have a very
high exposure to residential developments
on the mainland.
Because in reality, the Chinese economy
was slowing down, not by a great deal, but
from 8.5% to 7.5%.
Why do we think that was?
Because Europe was crap.
Europe was adding negatively to the export
market of China.
That's why it was capped out at 8.5%
growth and actually grew 7.5%.
But that started to come through over the
year.
So, that's the official PMI from 05.
That's HSBC final PMI.
So, what's that telling us now?
A big recovery is expected in China.
So, China is expected to grow faster.
But you've got to not confuse something in
China.
There's a big mistake that everybody makes
with China.
In the US, looking at the last 60 years,
you can quite easily conclude, from what
we've looked at today,
that the S&P 500 can be used as a
barometer or an instrument
to predict GDP and use it
to represent your view.
Unfortunately, in China, you can't do the
same.
One thing you should absolutely know as a
trader,
a good company doesn't mean a good stock.
The two aren't always linked.
Apple's a great company, but the stock's
being murdered.
The Chinese economy is fantastic,
but the Shanghai Composite goes down every
year.
Why does the Shanghai Composite go down
every year?
You've got to be careful.
So, you've got an economy that grows at
8%,
but the market goes down every year.
Why does that happen?
I actually did a speech last year in
August in Shanghai
at the Shanghai Hedge Fund Conference
to 125 hedge fund managers in Shanghai
and told them why.
And they all agreed to me.
So, it's called
The Shanghai Composite from the
Perspective of an International Trader.
And I just spoke for 30 minutes
and told them why.
And they all just sat there gobsmacked
that a guy would actually walk into China
and say it.
But it's true.
Okay.
Here's the reasons.
Always on the next slide.
Okay.
When you look at what happened in the
Western world
from 1950, 1960 onwards,
that's the baby boomer generation.
Population growth increasing
at an ever-increasing rate.
So, overall population growth
and a rate of change that's positive.
Yeah?
What happens
what actually happened
was
as those people
became adults,
they joined the workforce.
So, you have
an increased amount of consumers
but you also have
an increased amount of savers
because the US
actually had
a pensions infrastructure.
So, what do you need
for a market
to go up
structurally
over time
on a continual basis?
Two things.
One,
constant population growth.
Two,
a pensions infrastructure
because all those workers
beavering away
like little rabbits
every month
take
out of their
$2,000
that they get paid a month
$100
and they put it
in their pension.
the pension fund manager
then goes and
buys the market
with that $100.
So, what do you get
when you have
constant population growth
and a pensions infrastructure?
You get
a guaranteed buyer
of the stock market
every month
and demand outstripped supply
because no one wants
to sell it
because they know
the buyer will be back
next month.
That's what happens.
That's a structural bull market
here
over a number of decades
and your economy
can grow at 2%,
it can grow at 3%,
it can grow at any rate
it really wants.
If you have that
the market will go up
over many decades.
What happens
when that changes?
when you get
no population growth
and then
those guys
who were
saving for their pensions
now start
drawing their pensions?
The guaranteed
buyer of the stock market
turns into
a guaranteed seller
of the stock market
every month.
And this leads
to a huge decrease
in confidence
in the stock market.
That's exactly
what we're seeing
right now.
Because all the baby boomers
are retiring
and drawing their pensions
and their pensions
are tiny anyway.
But what you get now
is net outflows
every month
from US mutual funds
which means
the US market
no longer has
a guaranteed buyer.
the UK market
no longer
has a guaranteed buyer.
A guaranteed buyer
that's real.
Because that's real demand.
What's pretend demand?
Who's the buyer
of Western world
stock markets now?
The central banks.
The central banks
have replaced
the pension fund
as the buyer
of the Western world
stock market.
that's what's happened
in the last
four or five years.
So they're just
creating demand
that doesn't exist
to replace
real demand
that's disappeared.
What happens
in China?
This is what
happens in China.
Well first of all
you've got the US
and Europe
as your largest
export clients.
so when the US
grows in Europe
doesn't
you can't grow
your exports.
That's the first thing.
So they're doing
the right thing
by taking measures
to move their economy
to a more
domestically led
demand led economy.
Second
massive population
but no population
growth.
Single child policy.
Is it still
$10,000
for every child
that you have
over one
roughly speaking?
No pensions
infrastructure.
No one in China
puts their money
in the Shanghai
composite
and leaves it there
thinking they're
going to have a pension
when they're 65.
There's no culture
for pensions.
The cultural
propensity
is to invest
in tangible
assets.
So it's a very
different mindset.
The Hong Kong
property market
now
is on 28
times earnings.
The UK
is on 5
5.5 times
earnings.
The US
on about the same.
It doesn't
mean that it's
going down
from 28
times.
Because if it
drops by a
little bit
a guy on
the mainland
will just
buy it.
They're even
talking about
introducing
100 year
mortgages
in Hong Kong
like they
have in Japan
now.
And there's
the clue
as to what
could occur
in the
Western world
because the
first country
to experience
all of this
that we're
experiencing
now in the
Western world
was Japan.
because they
had the
first baby
boom
10 years
before the
Western world.
Superior
healthcare
system.
Yeah?
And what's
happened to
the Japanese
market?
They're on
quantitative
easing number
eight.
the central
bank has
been a
buyer of
the stock
market
since 1992.
And the
stock market
is down
75%.
So we
better be
careful in
the Western
world.
So if we
turn into
Japan that's
a real
problem.
And if the
US turns into
Japan.
But you've
got to read
between the
lines all the
time.
it's a
mistake to
look at
Chinese GDP
and say
because your
economy is
growing at
8%, I'm
going to
buy the
Shanghai
composite.
The profile
of the
Shanghai
composite every
year is
around November,
December,
everyone gets
excited about
next year.
Hey, we're
going to grow
at 8.5%
again.
Let's buy the
Shanghai
composite.
So people
go in and
buy it from
November,
December, all
the way up to
around mid-March,
April.
And then Q1
GDP is
reported and
then everyone
knows what
GDP is going
to be reported
in China for
the year around
that time.
Then what
happens?
There's no
buyer.
pensions.
There's no
population growth.
And people
don't put money
in the Shanghai
composite.
They put money
into property,
fine art,
tangible
assets.
And then the
market just
goes down.
So you'll
get the
Chinese PMI
data.
And you'll
get a
spreadsheet which
basically
predicts if
certain things
happen in the
US and Europe
when growth
expectations change,
how much that's
going to hit or
add to Chinese
exports and
therefore GDP.
it's all you
have to do.
They're all
connected.
So you just
work out if
Chinese growth
expectations are
too high or
too low and
vice versa.
So why do we
look at Chinese
GDP?
Well, in 12
years they could
literally be the
biggest economy in
the world and
they're growing at
8% so we have to
look at them and
consider them.
We'd be fools not
too.
So for
predicting Chinese
GDP, for
comparing European
US economic
fundamentals to
China, if
you've got
deterioration in
both, China's
going to struggle
to grow.
So expectations
might be too
high.
If you've got
good conditions
in the US or
improving conditions
in the US and
deteriorating
conditions in
Europe or one
cancels out the
other, China's
going to struggle
to grow beyond
the expected
level for the
year.
Obviously
forgetting your
world view,
generating ideas
in commodities,
currencies and
US, Europe and
rest of the world
that has exposure
to China.
So you get a
lot of companies,
especially for
example the
mining sector,
whose earnings
are well over
50%
exposed to
Chinese demand,
like miners,
materials and
commodities
companies.
Yeah?
So you don't
have to actually
go and trade in
Hong Kong or
trade the top
30 stocks in
China.
And the top
30 stocks in
China have
listings on the
New York Stock
Exchange anyway.
So you can trade
them in US
dollars.
But foreigners
can't actually,
oh, the other
reason I forgot
to add, it's
actually, well
there's limited
foreign purchases,
so all the
countries that have
pensions infrastructure
can't actually buy
Chinese stocks.
But in China you
can only go long
stock, you can't
short stock, so you
can't hedge
yourself.
You can go short
the index, so you
can go short the
Shanghai Composite.
But what happens
every single hedge
fund manager in
Shanghai, it's
crazy, has one
strategy, long
stock, short
index.
That's literally
all they can do.
So when a hedge
fund manager goes
out to pitch high
net worth in
institutions for
money, what's
your strategy?
Long stock, short
index.
Okay, so China
PMI numbers, useful
in four major
ways, predicting
Chinese GDP, comparing
Europe and US,
generating trade
ideas and
commodities,
currencies, and
rest of world
stocks that have
exposure to China.
That's important.
You can trade lots
of stocks in the
US, lots of
stocks in Europe,
totally based on
Chinese GDP
expectations through
the Chinese PMI.
What about other
countries like, for
example, Australia?
Anybody know what
percentage of the
Australian economy in
terms of exports
depends on Chinese
demand?
Lower?
It's between 30 and
40.
What happens if the
Chinese economy
slows down by
1%?
What happens to the
Australian economy?
No growth.
What happens to the
Aussie dollar?
Down.
Central banks need to
depreciate it to
increase exports.
You get all your
views from your
world view.
You just have to
start from the
top, work your
way down, and
you'll get there.
It just takes a bit
of practice.
Okay, welcome back.
We're going to do a
quick summary here of
Chinese GDP.
Now, from the
presentation, there's a
couple of things that
we have to take away
from analysing Chinese
GDP.
Our objective here is
to add Chinese GDP
into the global mix.
China's the second
biggest economy in the
world, and if we add
up the Eurozone, the
United States, and
China, we get to 50%
of global GDP.
So it's very, very
significant.
And when we look at
Chinese GDP and the
makeup of GDP, we get
to a very stark
conclusion.
70% is domestic
demand, domestic
consumption.
30% is exports.
So China really
depends on its export
market.
And we realise that
when we add up the
US and Europe, for
every 1% move in
GDP of US and
Europe combined, this
translates into a
move of Chinese GDP
of 10 basis points,
0.1%.
So let's just take
that for what it is
at the moment.
We're trying to look
at Chinese GDP here
in the bigger picture
and trying to use it
and trying to find a
useful way to take
Chinese GDP and turn
it into real money
as traders.
So when we're looking
at the PMIs, first
of all, we look at
the HSBC PMI and we
place more importance
on it.
The HSBC PMI has
got more companies
than the official PMI
and those companies
are small and medium
sized enterprises, SMEs.
Why is that important?
It's because their
earnings are more
sensitive to domestic
demand consumption,
domestic consumption
and also international
consumption through
exports in the US
and Europe.
So what you'll often
see when you look at
the HSBC PMI over
the official PMI is
divergence because the
HSBC PMI is moving
first.
The earnings of those
companies are more
sensitive.
So we take the HSBC PMI
and what we've also
realised in China when
looking at the
presentation is that
for a multitude of
reasons we can't use
the same causality that
we use in the United
States and Europe.
So if you recall in the
United States and
Europe we predict GDP
using the leading
indicators and we take
positions in the index,
commodities and
currencies and rates now.
And in the US we'll be
using primarily the S&P
500, in Europe we're
using the Euro stocks
600 and also the
domestic indices of
each country to predict
the GDP of those
countries and take
positions in them now.
But we can't do that in
China.
We can't do that for the
reasons highlighted in the
presentation.
The causality does not
work.
China has structural
issues in its stock
market.
Now if they fix these
structural issues the
Shanghai Composite will
become a much better
proxy for predicting GDP
and taking positions in
it now.
But we can't do that.
So how do we use the
HSBC PMI?
Well the best way to use
it is actually to take
positions outside of
China.
Now we can take
positions in China.
We can take positions as
international traders in
ETFs that represent the
Shanghai Composite.
But it's actually better
to go outside of China
and take positions in
Hong Kong, the United
States and Europe in the
stock market.
So we find sectors and
companies that have very
high percentage of their
revenue and their bottom
line, their profit.
Very high percentage of
both of those are
connected to Chinese GDP.
So we take positions in
the stock market there.
We also take positions in
commodities and
currencies.
Now for example, currency
situation, if you have a
country that has a very
high percentage of their
exports which are Chinese
demand led.
So Australia is a very
good example.
Australia's economy, very
high percentage of their
exports go to China.
And the value of the Aussie
dollar is very important
when looking at Chinese
GDP.
So we can trade the
Australian dollar when we
see the HSBC PMI
statistics.
We can trade commodities.
We can trade stocks
globally.
US, Europe, Hong Kong,
anywhere else where we
have stocks that have a
high percentage of their
revenue and profit linked to
Chinese GDP.
So that's how we use the
PMI in China as
professional traders.
We don't take positions in
the Shanghai composite
necessarily.
We can do through ETFs.
But we try and look for
smarter ways to play it as
well in stocks, sectors
around the world and in
currencies and in
commodities.
So that's really the end of
leading indicators.
We've gone through the US,
Europe and China.
You should congratulate
yourself.
You should give yourself a
little round of applause.
You've taken in a hell of a
lot of information because
now essentially what we've
got once we've been through
these processes at any one
point in time you will have
a world view.
You will have a view on
global GDP and you'll have
a view on regional GDP.
So we can even go to the
point where we're taking
positions like long United
States, short Europe.
Long Europe, short United
States.
Long China, short Europe,
long United States.
We can take these positions.
Now we've also got
positions in commodities.
We've also got positions in
commodities and rates.
When we're going in the
stock market we now have to
go to the next level.
So think of the big mind
map picture of the process
where we have idea
generation, we have
cleansing, which is the
gatekeeping section, we have
risk management, having
discipline, and we have the
trader statistics, the
self-awareness.
Now when we go in the stock
market and we go to the next
level we are still operating
within ideas.
We are now going from the
macro level to the micro
level which is the industry,
sector, and stock level.
So we're going to go over to the
next video first, which is
going to be a recap of
everything that we've learned
so far.
I think it's important to
basically clarify everything at
this stage, what we've
learned up to this point, and
then after that we're going to
take the next step which is to
go to the industry level within
the stock market.
Okay, let's go over to the next
video.
We'll do a recap and I'll see you
on the other side.